[Music]
hello and welcome to rate my drafts the
show where my guests decide whether my
drafts are perfect joke or unsalvageable
I wish I had more sage wisdom in fact I
wish I knew anything about herbs or how
to live a good I like it it's great yes
Forrest Gump okay so do you get the
joke it just didn't make me laugh
I think it's a joke they say you hurt
the ones you love but I didn't love the
kids I hit with my car and they got hurt
so bad
everyone loves violence right
violence is funny to me violence is
funny especially violence towards
children i silence for towards children
is funny according to the young turks i
mean i let me tell you i think it's
funny personally okay great but I feel
like just politically correctness a
tight grip I need to I got a stick with
red we're not getting under that bus
here's a fun fact did you know Microsoft
is also how Bill Gates describes his
penis
are you micro penis shaming Bill Gates
I'm not body shaming anyone I mean
that's I mean everyone heard it right I
love that one hey I just got a lot of
love for my micropenis brothers yeah
what's up nothing wrong with that just
got to be good at heaven saying let's
check out the windows 95 it's his
testers fun to do run up to someone
about to enter their home and yell hey
hold that door your face is what makes
it funny
you got a funny thing I don't think that
it's a perfect joke well it's a good
face in a perfect job it would be better
if you didn't read them which is how it
works which is great
[Music]
babes better my sleeve just came off
what oh my god
I left so hard I came out of my oh thank
you I'm doing there oh okay Wow outfit
change where's my love how's it look and
it matches you this is a really good set
can I make sure to get y'all's number my
number is five zero eight eight zero one
actually these text me compliments
that's when you got to do a little voice
oh people always talking about jumping
jacks but no one ever talking about
push-up fills all right I'd say the
closest I ever was so my mom was when I
was in her yeah perfect
okay that is that Islam gay okay
Blanche that's a perfect joke it's true
you turned me this was I wrote this last
week but it's really when I had sex with
my mom oh I didn't take it like that and
so if there was one that you might
retweet if I were to if I were to throw
them in the sky and then I would pick
any of them yeah I wish I had some more
sage wisdom it's so good can you tweet
it yeah I mean I know you've written it
I can give you some credits it's not
like Oh Hollywood well like I tried to
erase the name and say I wrote a magnum
p.i I'm already gonna do it you're gonna
tweet it and say - what would you know
what would you eat pizza yeah do ya do
that you do that right now of a very
good joke nice one drordy should we hit
the paddles yeah I got micropenis - boy
wait 1 2 3 micro penis boys can actually
cut that I don't want
that
[Music]